why don't like
there are tens on instagram people are
called tens you know i mean like they're
in here like looks wise yeah and i just
said to guys like
they're not real though right but i said
also
i said but what qualities does she have
because
for me as i get older i admire
the qualities of a woman over
the fact that she's a 10. 100
that's something that girls don't
understand and this is something i
didn't understand like i was one of the
girls that didn't get it i didn't
realize how many guys like
men are attracted to like more girls
than i thought
like i feel like guys attraction floor
is like lower than i thought for some
guys there was no attraction floor
no like whenever i i i would rate girls
like i'll talk about
like one to ten right and if i've ever
done it with a guy the guy always rates
the girl like higher than i would
oh really why do you think that is what
it looks wise yeah right
um why yeah
i don't know i just i think
[Laughter]
well you guys are attracted to them like
where i'm not
you know
so
no i think i think
quote unquote average looking women
with good qualities as a wife girlfriend
or partner i would take that over a 10
on instagram who's just abs airhead so
many
i would take that woman i think any day
if a guy's looking for something serious
he will go down in looks 100
to go up in
personality and that's what it is
cooperation
we don't because we always think it's
about looks like naturally we always
think it's just it's not
yeah and i think i think it's because of
like social media like even dating apps
now like that's
90 percent of it of your success rate is
going to be
predicated on looks because that's what
people are saying
instagram is all about what you're
showing like
so much of our attention currency is
based on looks
so everybody we all think about that oh
you think it's purely on looks but when
you get into real life it's there's more
than that have you ever been catfished
where a girl didn't look at all like her
profile yes yeah
why are you laughing
you got a story you just tell us the
story right now
she did it up in jail
um
you know do you not know this app called
um beagle
no it's a live streaming
uh app and you live stream and you can
get these things called um
i think they're called coins or gems or
something and um you basically get paid
for just
um streaming basically okay that's what
bigo is but anyone can log on
um
you can you guys can make an account now
and there could be ones in america china
uk whatever free sponsor
basically i was on there one day
and you can have private chats
i was on a one day
and i had uh i went into someone's room
and they were discussing i've got a
discussion but they were discussing
something
and then there was this girl had a nice
um
display picture was nice
yeah so uh sorry i um
i followed her and then she started
talking to me surprising yeah so she
started talking to me
and then she invited me to a private
chat
cool talking to her talking to her
talking to her she gave me her number
eventually
had her number
and we're talking
and eventually just to cut a whole long
story eventually
she was like to me
that she's a he
oh mate oh
so oh so this whole time i'm talking
like i'm talking to
her guy yeah
but was it sexual talk
oh
[Music]
a couple couple months later i get a
call from him
dad and listen i just had to just hang
up the phone how did you find out she
wasn't here because
like me like
jesus because i'm not really like i'll
basically i'll get i'll just get bored
i'll do what i need and i'll just i'm
just like
you're gone yeah right and then
like if there's no like
yeah there's nothing keeping you there
mentally yeah yeah
i'm going um and then
it was just like
i don't know what to call him
[Music]
yeah but she was just like oh why are
you airing me you're just hearing me did
it or whatever because i was aiming for
time and then
eventually that's when
he said oh yeah
i'm a i'm a boy
cause i was just there from the uk from
the uk from the uk and it was scary
because he called me a month after man
and
yeah i just had to let him know no
that's not here it's not it was not and
i told him as well it's not even a thing
because the first time he told me i was
like yeah bro
nah and then you call me again i was
thinking brother now you're trying to
take a piss because i've already done
told you like yeah yeah yeah of course
yeah man but yeah that's my story that's
why i laughed because you always said
catfish by a girl no
i have i've never had that but i've had
it where
um where like a couple of my friends if
they're on dating apps then they match
with this girl who's like sorry they
match with this girl who's like
a nine or a 10.
and she starts speaking he's like my
gosh i match this girl she started
speaking to me first i'm like
and then he checks the profile checks
the description
oh i'm
a man or i used to be a man whatever and
i'm like half the honestly i feel like
if it's a really really really
attractive girl
and she's initiating with you
i just always assumed that i'm like
something suspicious
there's something suspicious because
girls like that have so much dick thrown
at them yeah they don't change anything
yeah it's true
you'll be surprised though because it's
like that's happened to me before and
i'm like
that's what me yeah yeah
hey listen
what's in a blue moon it all happened
like i'm about
a couple of do you know love island
i
vaguely like i've heard of it oh okay
i've dated a couple of people from there
before but it's just and not that they
made a move but they made it very
obvious that they were into me and it's
just because i was their type so if
you're all down to a if you're like if
you're a girl's type down to a t then
she might right then she might do you
know